now I was also in Georgia recently for
our three mil Series where we break
bread with voters in key states to hear
what's on their mind polling shows the
economy is the top issue for registered
voters there 66 percent say the country
is on the wrong track only 19 percent
say things are headed in the right
direction we took a road trip through
Georgia for some good food and even
better conversation
[Applause]
all right
it's morning here in Atlanta Georgia
and if it's morning here in Atlanta the
silver Skillets Grill has been hot for
hours
[Music]
for more than half a century probably
economy's number one economy is number
one
so many other Americans and Susan Reeder
is feeling the effects of inflation
and credits incumbent Republican
Governor Brian Kemp for trying to keep
prices down the state has done very well
our governor our current governor has
helped us with gas prices he's taken the
gas tax off every single day you go to
the grocery store to buy food it costs
more you go to the gas station it costs
more paychecks aren't going up so you
have to make changes will we have
election integrity and confidence and
election results Michael Sullivan has
lived in Atlanta for nearly 40 years he
worries about free and fair elections
and we're going to have a rule of law
applied to call balls and Strikes on
elections which I think
Georgia showed a pretty good example of
an the last election in 2020 Georgia
officials certified Joe Biden's victory
in the state over Donald Trump despite
alleged pressure to reverse the outcome
sometimes people don't even necessarily
vote for a particular party they're
voting against the other party it's sort
of tragic and without you know looking
at what people where do people derive
their moral code from I mean a lot of
people in this country or let's say if
you're Christian love one another right
where's that gone
for lunch we're headed south along
Interstate 75. through the historic
cotton growing region of the state Macon
Georgia once a rural farming Outpost
Macon still holds those same qualities
but this region is now known for retail
and Manufacturing Bibb County went for
President Biden in 2020 but the city is
splintered between two congressional
districts the second is majority
Democrat in the 8th District majority
Republican
[Music]
[Applause]
before lunch that will stick to your
ribs and conversation that will long
stick in your mind H restaurant is where
it's at
this spot has been helping power making
and its rock stars for Generations but
when you're voting
what's on your mind
gun laws and abortion we met Tamika
Johnson as she settled into her cup of
coffee it's too easy it's almost like I
can go into the gas station put 10 on
pump nine give me a pack of Newports
short and hand me that 22 over there we
shock Monroe v Wade was
reversed I was like this
Rover's waving around like but yeah but
then y'all wake up one day I don't feel
like being bothered with it let's change
it the only reason I pay attention to
right now is Warnock and hurts Gary
Heath was born and raised in Macon the
race for U.S Senate between incumbent
Democrat Rafael Warnock and Republican
Challenger Herschel Walker will help
decide what party controls the Senate
it's one of the closest most expensive
and controversial elections in the
country and I find it incredible
put it for that race to be as tight as
what they said is why when you got a man
on TV constantly lying
you mean Herschel her should walk why
would you even consider putting a man
like that up down the city and you
cannot trust what he's saying now don't
get me wrong now when he played college
football I like it but I don't believe
the word come out of his mouth
for dinner we're making our way down
south to Georgia's Coast
to the oldest city in the state known as
the hostess of the South Savannah which
is a port city fourth largest in America
to be exact
now around here it's known as low
country because of its proximity to sea
level okay what would you like
I'm starving
I seriously mean that
now you know we couldn't leave Georgia
without some proper barbecue we call
this our meat candy it's got a little
bit of sweetness to it the award-winning
Wiley's Championship BBQ is Nate
Shafer's place and as we quickly
realized
chicken up meal at Wiley's feels like
the family dining room table I want to
see them talking about how we're all
going to do better
is a retired federal agent and I think
most people vote with their pocket right
what's going on Halfway Around The World
is it an important issue to me when I'm
when I'm at the booth it's it's how how
my family is doing economically it's
more important this is so divided Clara
Jackson believes the country is moving
apart and says abortion is a key issue
when she's voting and it's just like I
think I heard someone say this morning
you know it's between there guys word
you know their faith in their body
and I think that's who it should be
between so when they reverse Roe v Wade
how did you feel
um I felt like something had been taken
away from women something they've been
fighting for for years and now all of a
certain year ago is back again
huge shout out to the people of Georgia
who sat down with me and of course the
Silver Skillet H restaurant in Wiley's
Championship barbecue you know I can't
confirm Southern Hospitality is real I
could tell and they're giving out
trophies for barbecue Down to Georgia
pretty serious they sure do and you know
the topics that were on everybody's mind
their economy abortion and gun loss and
you can tell that that was the reason
why you might be seeing those record
numbers as people are coming out and
hitting the polls early and you know
it's just so interesting when you look
at you the Herschel Walker question that
came up there we didn't really get into
it earlier with Leslie and Ashley but
this idea of these October surprises
that used to derail a campaign in
Georgia there for some voters some
things seem to matter and other people
look at it and is simply they want to
vote along their party lines and
something doesn't matter as much to them
it's it's really like it's tailor-made
for them and each issue is so different
for each person obviously yeah and you
can see what a star though Herschel
Walker was though as a football player
even the guy who was criticizing him had
to be now don't get me wrong he could
play football he might not get my vote
but he was a beast on the field all
right great job Nate thank you